[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue dans ce journal du lundi 25
mars tout de suite les titres de cette
édition et vers des habitations
connectés numérique le bailleur les
résidences yvelines essonne il réfléchit
pour son parc de 31 mille logements
sociaux répartis sur les deux
départements
une expérimentation est réalisé en ce
moment dans un appartement témoin et des
projets seront lancés d'ici la fin de
l'année plus de 800 millions de
personnes souffrent de la faim dans le
monde lohan gccf des terres solidaires
se mobilisent pour lutter contre le
phénomène la délégation des yvelines
organise plusieurs conférences pour
expliquer les causes et montrer que des
solutions existent nous recevons son
président philippe thellier et puis
retour sur la troisième édition de
l'estacade redresse la course de drones
organisée par des étudiants de l'école
d'ingénieurs basée à montigny le
bretonneux 15 pilotes ont pris le départ
sur un circuit entièrement plongée dans
le noir est balisé grâce à des led et
les forum jobs d'été reviennent
également dans les yvelines nous en
parlons tout à l'heure avec laurence
cousin à directrice d'yveline
information jeunesse
mais avant de développer ces titres une
famille de lyme est soupçonné d'abus
sexuels sur au moins trois filles âgées
de 6 à 8 ans un homme de 50 ans son
épouse et leur fils de 18 ans ont été
mis en examen par la cour de versailles
procédure ouverte après les révélations
d'une adolescente et d'une fillette qui
ont été placés dans cette famille une
troisième enfant handicapé aurait
également subi des violences les trois
accusés ni pour le moment les faits 22
enfants en tout serait passé par cette
famille depuis 2010 l'ouverture à paris
aujourd'hui du procès en appel
d'abdelkader meira le frère du
terroristes des attentats de toulouse et
montauban en 2012 condamné à 20 ans de
prison en 2010 est l'homme est jugé
cette fois ci pour complicité d cet
assassinat motifs non retenu lors du
premier jugement
et parmi la partie civile dans ce procès
samuel sandler l'ancien président de la
communauté juive de versailles est le
père de jonathan et grand-père darier et
gabriel tué à l'école juive dawesar à
tora de toulouse
un square à leurs noms avaient
d'ailleurs été inaugurée en 2015 à
versailles samuel sandler souhaite comme
les autres familles de victimes que la
complicité des meurtres soient reconnus
pour ce procès en appel qui se tient
jusqu'au 19 avril et des hlm bientôt
connectés le bailleur les résidences
yvelines essonne réfléchi à la question
il présentait son appartement témoin la
semaine dernière un logement contrôlée
par tablettes et téléphones portables
les détails avec ce sujet de mélanie
poker ça fonctionne en bluetooth
donc quand je vais approcher de la vie
nationale lamassoure automatiquement
accéder à son appartement avec son
téléphone c'est le futur qu'envisagent
les résidences yvelines essonne le
bailleur social des deux départements
aujourd'hui on part du principe que la
modernité va être tout ce qui est les
nouvelles technologies le numérique qui
va permettre d'apporter des services
supplémentaires aux locataires et
rendent les logements aussi attractif
un point de vue conforme capteurs sur
les portes et fenêtres calcul de la
température de l'humidité ou encore des
dépenses énergétiques du foyer des
installations adaptable en fonction des
besoins des locataires familles
personnes âgées ou à mobilité réduite
près de 7500 euros c'est le montant
estimé pour équiper les futurs logements
on est d'ailleurs en a vocation à loger
des personnes
donc on doit bien les loger et comme en
plus de ça les personnes sont si
modestes
c'est une question si des tic pour nous
que de leur apporter le même niveau de
confort si ce n'est au niveau de confort
plus élevé que dans le parc privé
ces deux petites électrodes quand on les
refait son retard road again de l'eau et
vont venir
m'alerter sur mon téléphone quand j'ai
une suite mais aussi couper l'eau deux
projets vont être lancés d'ici la fin de
l'année à chanteloup les vignes au
val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie les
résidences yvelines essonne héberge
actuellement près de 200 mille
locataires sur les deux départements
on va parler solidarité avec mon premier
invité philippe thellier bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de la délégation
des yvelines du ccfd terre solidaire et
vous organisé plusieurs conférences sur
le territoire dans les prochains jours
avec pour thème la faim dans le monde
820 athée 821 millions de personnes en
souffrent aujourd'hui alors plusieurs
causes et les remèdes existent c'est
l'objet d'ailleurs de vos conférences
qu'on va présenter dans un instant est
déjà le ccfd terre solidaire c'est une
ong catholique alors le principal cheval
de bataille c'est cette lutte contre la
faim dans le monde mais il ya aussi une
lutte plus général contre toutes les
injustices sa sainte a fait d'un son nom
le ccfd porte en effet le nom de la fin
puisque c'est comité catholique contre
la faim et pour le développement
cela a été écrit en 1961 suite à un
appel de l'aef à eau pour juguler ce
grand problème mondial de la faim et le
ccfd a comme suffixes terre solidaire
puisque on se veut solidaire de tout ce
qui peut opprimer les populations du sud
et de l'est puisque ce sont
essentiellement qui sont victimes du
problème de la faim alors on arrive à
toucher 2 millions virgule 2
personne dans le monde grâce à cette
action là et bien qu'on soit catholique
on ne demande pas du tout si les gens
font partie de telle ou telle obédience
religieuse peu importe ça c'est
essentiel c'est que les partenaires sur
lesquels nous nous appuyons dans les
pays mettent en avant des valeurs qui
fasse que ça profite à la population de
leur territoire alors manger à sa faim
c'est un droit fondamental justement
comment le ccfd s'attache à faire
respecter ce droit fondamental dans le
monde quels sont les types d'actions
développés
voilà alors on s'appuie sûr on a
quelques 700 projets on s'appuie sur 400
partenaires lorsqu'on entend par
partenaires ce sont des souvent des
associations locales
parce qu'on n'en voit pas de d'experts
on n'envoie pas de mission en tant que
tel occidentales on considère que ce
sont les populations locales qui sont
les mieux à même de gérer leur problème
est de savoir qu'est ce qui convient le
mieux pour résoudre ces problèmes là
donc c'est déjà en s'appuyant sur eux et
ensuite on met en avant mais bien par
exemple des programmes de d'agroécologie
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse éviter
l'érosion des terres qu'on puisse
cultiver de façon très intelligente et
moderne si je puis dire
à partir de là de l'agriculture locale
et pour promouvoir les cultures
vivrières et surtout faire en sorte que
la population puisse se nourrir
à partir de ce qu'ils produisent sur
place selon l'anrt pendant 1 0
écologique ce que ça fait partie de
l'une des solutions qui a mis en avant
lors de ses conférences on l'a dit plus
de 800 millions de personnes qui
souffrent de la faim quelles sont les
causes de la faim dans le monde qu'est
ce qui fait aujourd'hui qu'on a sont ce
chiffre très élevé on recense en gros
cinq causes confondues qui provoque la
faim dans le monde alors d'abord les
conflits armés et la guerre et on peut
citer par exemple quand j'hésite
toujours des exemples qui paraissent qui
ont été un peu occultés dans les médias
c'est que l'est le conflit en syrie il a
d'abord été due à cinq années de
sécheresse qui ont mis un million et
demi de personnes
dans les villes dans les bidonvilles et
ensuite c'est tout était prêt pour une
explosion sociale et on connaît la suite
il en a été de même avec 5 millions de
personnes suite à cinq années de
sécheresse également au nigeria qui ont
poussé les populations déserté dans les
villages pour verbe boko haram et les
islamistes radicaux
donc il ya les confirmés vous l'avez
évoqué aussi d'ordre environnemental
aussi une cause environnementale
il ya en effet en lutte conte le une
deuxième cause c'est la disparition de
la biodiversité
par exemple est ce qu on sait que ces
quatre grandes multinationales qui
possède 60% des semences dans le monde
donc les agriculteurs ne sont plus sont
de moins en moins
auteurs de leur propre semis et donc il
y à une dépendance accrue vis-à-vis des
accrocs industrie qui ne sont pas dans
leur pays
la troisième cause c'est le dérèglement
climatique on sait que les par exemple
la remontée des niveaux des mers voit
surtout attaque t ces populations là les
petites îles indonésiennes et autres et
puis il y a comment dire le
la spéculation qui provoque l'évasion
fiscale et qui fait que ces pays là ne
vivent pas de leur ressource
l'extraction minière par exemple à cause
des paradis fiscaux n'est pas parce
qu'elle devrait ou pays où on extrait
par exemple les minerais comme le coltan
nécessaires à nos téléphones portables
et pourtant des solutions existent on
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est l'objectif
des conférences de mettre en avant ses
solutions notamment des solutions au
timor oriental alors ce pays qui est de
une île dans l'océan indien
l'agroécologie qu'est ce que c'est
l'agroécologie qui est mis en place
justement en fait c'est la mise en avant
d'une culture paysanne respectueuse de
l'environnement donc sans intrants
chimiques et qui permet de juguler par
exemple les phénomènes d'érosion mais
aussi d'optimiser au mieux tout ce qui
est culture vivrière d'associer les
cultures entre elles par exemple vous
allez avoir légumineuses qui fournit de
l'azoté dans le sol qui va profiter aux
cultures légumières à côté il ya tout un
système que d'agroforesterie pour que
justement cette culture profitent de
l'ombre et c'est enfin tout ce qu'on
développe aussi en france le taux de
l'agroécologie ça s'apparente au bio
savent qu'il ya pas de label là bas et
au timor il pousse le bouchon tellement
loin que ils vont jusqu'à la
permaculture est le partenaire qu'on
veut faire venir par exemple demain soir
à voisins il va parler de ça puisque lui
même est à l'origine d'une loi dans son
pays qui a obligé à chaque chef
d'établissement scolaire de créer un
jardin de permaculture pour les enfants
donc ça c'est une première conférence
qui est au programme demain à la salle
canne à deux voisins le bretonneux c'est
à 20h30 et il y aura également deux
autres conférences sur cette même
thématique à la salle du presbytère de
rambouillet ça c'est le 3 avril à 20h et
le 4 avril à la crypte notre dame du
chêne à viroflay une autre thématique
qui nous reste 30 secondes environ
c'est aussi demain c'est à marly-le-roi
c'est sur la pêche puis la pêche
artisanale alors là c'est la défense des
pêcheurs artisanaux et notamment entre
l'implantation de grosses
infrastructures on cite le port city
c'est à dire que gouvernement veut a
vendu paraît-il des territoires
maritimes à la chine et donc ses
pêcheurs vont être disons évacués de
leur zone alors qu'ils ont besoin des
protéines des poissons pour pour vivre
et donc ça remet en cause et la bio
diversité et la souveraineté alimentaire
de ces populations là et on retrouve
bien sûr toutes les informations sur ces
conférences sur le site du comité du
ccfd solidaire des yvelines et aussi
pour donner au ccfd solidaire j'invite
les téléspectateurs à se rendre sur le
site internet de l'organisation au
niveau national merci à philippe
thellier yade est revenue sur ce plateau
président de la délégation des yvelines
du ccfd terre solidaire solidarité
toujours mais cette fois ci entre les
sept départements d'ile-de-france pour
financer des deux grands projets
l'objectif du fonds d'investissement le
fonds de solidarité interdépartemental
d'investissement une enveloppe de 150
millions d'euros sera consacré cette
année à ce f s2i explications dont ce
sujet de nos confrères de via grand
paris il l'avait annoncé voici un an au
salon des maires les présidents des
départements d'île de france allaient se
serrer les coudes pour céder à financer
leurs projets c'est maintenant fait ils
l'ont annoncé ce jeudi
il débloque 150 millions d'euros une
bonne nouvelle pour le président de
seine et marne qui pourra ainsi financer
plus facilement ses projets son
département est confronté chaque année à
une arrivée de 13 mille nouveaux
habitants nous accueillons beaucoup de
la populace de beaucoup population est
cette population vient essentiellement
des autres départements franciliens
donc cette solidarité entre départements
d'abord est compréhensible et elle va
nous permettre d'encore mieux accueillir
ces personnes qui viennent des autres
départements ces 150 millions
financeront en 2019
une quarantaine de projets notamment
dans l'éducation vous avez des projets
de mobilité vous avez des projets qui
concernent l'éducation on a en ile de
france et en grande couronne une
augmentation de population très
important et donc on a besoin de
construire des collèges donc on a décidé
par exemple que les collèges qui sont en
zone prioritaire en politique de la
ville en rep serait favorisée par le
projet interdépartemental c'est l'avenir
de nos franciliens les départements les
plus riches financeront les projets des
départements les plus pauvres
la seine-saint-denis percevra ainsi 40
millions d'euros 30 % du fonds
d'investissement l'île de france qui est
caractérisée à la fois par de grandes
richesses ne s'y par de profondes
inégalités
un des principes fondateurs de ce fonds
de ceulaer a été un terreau
départementale c'était la redistribution
la redistribution des territoires les
plus riches vers les territoires les
plus pauvres premier contributeur de ce
fonds
le département des hauts-de-seine nous
allons investir dans ce budget de 150
millions 62 millions par les
hauts-de-seine ce qui représente 41% sur
parce que ce qui se passe dans les
départements voisins touche évidemment
notre département des hauts-de-seine il
les problèmes ne sont pas si localisable
que ça
ce fonds va permettre d'accélérer la
réalisation de projets seront
accompagnés les dossiers en matière de
solidarité d'éducation de mobilité de
patrimoine d'environnement de rénovation
urbaine et même des projets concernant
les jeux olympiques financer ses
vacances ses projets ou tout simplement
acquérir une première expérience
professionnelle de nombreux jeunes se
tournent vers les jobs d'été en
avril-mai et en mars aussi adhémar
sybille information jeunesse leur
consacre des forums dans les yvelines
bonsoir laurence cousin mensonge d'état
directrice des yvelines information
jeunesse la structure départementale qui
accueillent informent et conseillent et
documente des jeunes alors plusieurs
forum jobs d'été qui vont se dérouler
dans le premier c'est ce mercredi à la
salle des fêtes de gargenville de 14h à
18h l'objectif c'est de
de couvrir tout le territoire des
yvelines puis on a sur différents lieux
d'exactement et on a la chance d'être un
réseau donc la force du réseau basse et
d'être nombreux donc on est une dizaine
d' informateur jeunesse de structures
labellisées information jeunesse sur le
territoire et donc on mutualise ses
forum jobs d'été sur trois dates cette
année alors les trois dates donc c'est
le premier ce mercredi à gargenville il
y aura un deuxième forme le 10 avril à
la salle des fêtes de bois d'arcy et le
15 mai c'est à l'espace culturel paul
gauguin 200 poulets ligne c'est pourquoi
il est intéressant de cette formule du
job d'été pour les jeunes alors la
formule jobs d'été elle est intéressante
si c'est un dating version mais si on
peut être mis en relation avec des
recruteurs parce que tout au long de
l'année dans les centre information
jeunesse finalement ils peuvent
s'informer préparer leur cv avoir des
pistes de job d affichage d'offres
notamment là l'intérêt vraiment premier
c'est de rencontrer les recruteurs et de
pouvoir poser son cv est ce qu'ils sont
nombreux les jeunes à s'informer sur les
jobs d'été c'est une question qui les
intéressent ça reste une question qui
les intéresse est le premier pas vers
l'autonomie donc nous c'est quand même
une des missions principales que l'on
avec le réseau et puis on a comparé
forcément le choix ils veulent financer
leur permis ils veulent financer des
projets personnels et vacances
donc c'est le moyen idéal pour le faire
qui peut faire un job d'été est ce qu'il
ya un âge minimum pour commencer à quel
âge peut-on copa georges également 16
ans même si c'est compliqué pour les
plus jeunes et notamment les mineurs
c'est pas complètement fermé c'est vrai
que gargenville par exemple ouvre à
partir de 18 ans pour les autres dates
c'est à partir de 16 ans alors il n'y a
pas de garantie de trouver le job
après il faut on l'a on accompagne les
jeunes notamment sur l'élaboration du
cvc tels que font ils ont eu si j'ai pas
grand chose à mettre mais en fait on
peut les accompagner pour valoriser
aussi leur expérience de stage ou extra
professionnelles sportifs ou autres
et puis de réfléchir aussi combien de
temps je suis disponible parce que c'est
vrai que s'ils n'ont aucune expérience à
16 ans qui sont disponibles une semaine
deux le temps qu'ils s'adaptent pour
l'employeur va il va repartir et sait
pas si intéressant que ça donc aussi
leur faire prendre conscience un petit
peu voilà c'est le genre de choses il ya
des secteurs multiples dans lesquels on
peut faire des jobs d'été où finalement
quelques secteurs seulement alors disons
que je veux ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est effectivement que ce soit
accessible puisque qui dit jobs d'été
dit quelquefois première expérience donc
il faut que ça reste accessible sans
trop d'exigences
d'expérience ou autre donc c'est vrai
qu'à des secteurs privilégiés comme
l'hôtellerie restauration l'animation
socioculturelle d'ailleurs le bafa est
accessible dès 17 ans donc ils peuvent
se former éventuellement la vente le
commerce ça peut aussi être des pistes
et on a d'autres services à la personne
la motivation c'est mettre aux mots de
réfléchir aussi à ce qu'on a envie de
faire
et puis les priorités c'est gagner de
l'argent c'est aussi se faire plaisir
faire quelque chose qui nous intéresse
et on entendait les larges envoyer ses
des questions qu'il faut se poser aussi
peut-être aussi s'ouvrir culturellement
parce que c'est possible de faire des
jobs d'été à l'étranger en tout cas
c'est alors à chaque fois bien pour moi
la lettre au desk donc du coup tout ce
qui est mobilité européenne et
internationale ont pris vie j'ai
toujours cet axe donc il y aura des
offres effectivement à l'international
sur des emplois ces années tout à fait
qu'est ce que pourront trouver ces
jeunes justement sur sur ces trois forum
jobs d'été
quelles informations qu'elle recruteurs
seront seront présents quelques l
entreprise pour l'accompagnement sur les
trois dates il y a automatiquement mais
le réseau information jeunesse en amont
pour avoir des conseils mais aussi la
mission locale d'autres partenaires qui
peuvent accompagner sur le cv la lettre
de motivation des simulations
d'entretien ça peut être intéressant
il y aura des affichages d'offres au
delà des recruteurs sur place même si
encore une fois ce sont les recruteurs
qui sont privilégiés il ya à peu près
une quinzaine de recruteurs sur place
sur chaque chaque forum avec différents
beaucoup de commerces ventes services à
la personne animation socioculturelle
hôtellerie restauration principalement
on essaie d'avoir aussi les offres de
l'anefa sur les cueillettes des offres
aussi en mobilité internationale
mais ça c'est plus un affichage donc
trois dates proposées par yveline
information jeunesse fit également
d'autres dates du réseau qui au fond en
solo parce que par exemple par
embrouiller sont un petit peu excentré
donc rambouillet ce sera le 18 mai
rambouillet donc bouge ton était donc
des offres de jobs mais aussi de l'été
utile si vous voulez ça peut des
chantiers internationaux
c'est avec les mineurs on peut aussi les
engager sur des dispositifs intéressant
et qui ne sont pas forcément du job mais
mais qui permettra à ces jeunes de
rencontrer différentes personnes et de
s'engager sur un projet s'appelle bien
sur le cv aussi donc on retrouve bien
sûr toutes ses dates sur le site
d'yvelines information jeunesse merci
laurence besoin d'être passé sur ce
plateau directrice divine information
jeunesse
partons à la découverte d'une confrérie
à présent elle défend depuis quatre ans
la pl poule et le pâté de houdan se met
très réputé autrefois a quasiment
disparu
une cérémonie d'intronisation avait lieu
hier dimanche à la salle des fêtes de
houdan michael et demi d'euros et au
rayon ils sont désormais les
ambassadeurs et les défenseurs de
produits qui ont failli disparaître la
poule et le pâté de houdan depuis 2016
une soixantaine d'adhérents font partie
de cette confrérie qui organisait son
quatrième chapitre il s'agit d'une
réunion annuelle la communauté intronise
de nouvelles personnes au cours d'une
cérémonie bien particulière on a une
épreuve c'est de manger le pâté on voit
un petit verre de vin blanc pour pour le
faire passer également et ensuite eh
bien on jure sur un serment comme quoi
on devient des ambassadeurs de cette
confrérie où on va dire une bande d'amis
ils se réunissent régulièrement pour
organiser ce genre de réception
trente et une personnes ont été
intronisées certaines viennent d'autres
confréries gastronomiques d'autres sont
des personnalités toutes ont à coeur de
défendre ce mets de choix qui était
notamment servi sur la table de louis
xiv
c'est vrai que le pâté de houdan c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment une
tradition locale et je pense que ça doit
se défendre parce que chaque région doit
défendre son patrimoine et patrimoine
gastronomique c'est aussi quelque chose
de très important
ce quatrième chapitre s'est terminée par
un défilé en ville ça fait revivre un
peu le centre de ou non qui se meurt
donc ça fait du bien on voit que les
traditions sont perpétuées qu' il ya
encore du monde qui s'intéresse au
patrimoine et au terroir français et
c'est assez important de préserver sa
aujourd'hui très prochainement le pâté
de houdan figurera sur la carte de
grands palaces parisiens et cet
événement a vu également la création
d'une nouvelle confrérie celle du miel
le miel des yvelines les six personnes
qui la composent viennent
essentiellement de plaisir et grâce
c'était cette officialisation elles vont
pouvoir désormais mieux faire connaître
et reconnaître leurs produits auprès du
public est mais aussi auprès d'autres
confréries gastronomiques avant de
connaître les principaux résultats
sportifs du week-end retour à présent
sur la troisième édition de l'estacade
roseraie c'était ce samedi sur le site
de l'école d'ingénieurs basée à montigny
le bretonneux 15 pilotes se sont
affrontés sur le circuit conçu par les
étudiants de l'estaca modélisme nicolas
nombreux
[Musique]
ils passent en moyenne de 0 à 120
km/heure en trois secondes ces drones
sont programmés pour la course des
p'tits bolides volant à quatre hélices
télécommande est piloté grâce à un
casque connecté à une caméra
[Musique]
2 5 pouces sont justement pour les
parkings le plus grand plus de puissance
et donc là je de régler de façon à avoir
vraiment de tâches tout dans la danse
dans la trajectoire et la caméra donc
réguler luminosité puisqu'on est dans
partout d'accès on a tous en parking du
coup c'est un endroit très continue donc
du coup au niveau espace pour une
machine qui soit pas trop puissante pour
éviter de taper le plafond s'est passé
se passe plutôt bien je n'ai pas tapé
mais ça va plutôt bien
un circuit lumineux dans le sous sol de
l'école d'ingénieurs de montigny le
bretonneux cette troisième édition de la
course de drones a rassemblé 15 pilotes
organisé par l'association estac à
modélisme
[Musique]
nous plongeons le parking dans le noir
et nos balises ont le circuit à l'aide à
l'aide de l'aide justement est ce qui
permet vraiment aux pilotes d'avoir un
circuit assez atypique et et ce qui
suscite leur curiosité
cette course entre dans le calendrier de
l'association avec comme objectif de
démocratiser cette pratique sportive
naissante
[Musique]
il est de retour pour ses résultats
sportifs du week-end michael et demi
d'euro bonds soir sans grégory par
l'actualité sportive encore une fois
chargé on va commencer cette chronique
en prenant notre respiration est ce que
vous avez déjà vu une performance à
couper le souffle
bah écoutez vous allez nous en parler
voilà c'était le cas ce dimanche au
centre aquatique de saint cyr l'école
franco cuve à andy cabreira avila que
vous voyez à l'image avec son aileron de
dauphin réalisé un nouveau record après
avoir nagé en apnée dynamique pendant
six heures et 12 heures ces dernières
années cette fois ci il ne respirait que
4 minutes et 12 secondes pendant six
heures d'apnée statique c'est énorme
un défi qu'il s'est lancé pour dénoncer
la maltraitance des animaux marins dans
les parcs aquatiques
on écoute la réaction de ce champion
juste à la sortie de son record il ya
beaucoup de choses qui bougent à bout en
bout un godet c'est dans ce top une
surelance pis c'est difficile c'est
autant de l'avoir fait mais j'ai pas aux
gains de capacité pulmonaire donc 10
juin que ma force de la volonté laisser
dégât des eaux mon mental
elle est pensée à como france
le nageur espère également avoir réussi
son autre défi sensibiliser le grand
public sur la cause animale
on parle maintenant au baseball michael
direction montigny le bretonneux oui
agoria je vois que vous suivez bien
l'actualité sportive du département les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
finaliste malheureux la saison passée de
première division repartent au combat
pour aller chercher leur graal et ils
ont plutôt bien réussi leurs débuts ce
dimanche ils se sont imposés 9 à 0 et 9
à 2 sur les deux matchs contre les
cavigal de nice lors de la première
journée du championnat
quelles sont les attentes des supporters
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre qui
remporte le championnat
et qui retourne en finale l'année
dernière fois les est en finale si j'ai
pas de bêtises donc qui retourne en
finale et qui gagne qui gagnent la coupe
d'europe à brno au mois de juin ça
serait super
en championnat qui gardent leur place en
finale ce serait comme l'année dernière
ça serait super après peut-être battront
c'est possible voilà des belles
victoires simplement
voilà bah oui tu as déjà ce serait pas
mal un jeu très très optimiste pour
l'avenir
il ya une très bonne cohésion groupe et
je pense que le travail de cet hiver va
payer encore plus loin cette année nous
sommes en national et puis aussi
d'europe ça les supporters vont ils être
satisfaits de lait des performances de
leurs protégés
réponse dans quelques mois grand vide
par le résultat de rugby michael alors
on termine donc ce tour d'horizon par
une note très positive le rugby-club de
versailles fêté ce week-end la montée en
fédérale 3 devant des centaines de
supporters dans une ambiance électrique
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
et les joueurs l'auront fait plaisir en
l'emportant 37 à 12 face à clichy leur
16e victoire en 16 matches disputées ils
tenteront maintenant de remporter le
championnat de france pour que la fête
soit encore plus belle
merci ces résultats bien d'autres encore
dans votre émission le cetud pourra
retrouver dans un instant après ce
journal et puisqu'on parle de sport
petit clin d'oeil un grand monsieur du
commentaire il ya tout juste 11 ans
disparaissait thierry gilardi le 25 mars
2008 le journaliste passé par les
rédactions de canal+ et de tf1 succombé
à une crise cardiaque à l'âge de 49 ans
thierry gilardi était né à saint germain
en laye et résidait à montfort l'amaury
où il est enterré aujourd'hui c'est la
fin du set 8 journal merci de votre
fidélité chez belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]